from the american museum of natural
history in new york city
and beaming out across all of space and
time
this is star talk where science and pop
culture
collide welcome
to the hall of the universe right here
in new york city i am neil degrasse
tyson
your personal astrophysicist and tonight
we are featuring my interview
with the one the only the american
legend the hero
buzz aldrin buzz aldrin
pilot of the apollo 11 mission to the
moon
so let's do this i never do this alone
and i've got my professional comedian
co-host eliza schlesinger thank you
eliza welcome thank you welcome
and i i also have a person who's
actually been into space
the one and only mike massimino mike
welcome back
to starfall great great to be here and
mike massimino you're one of my favorite
astronauts ever
because you helped to fix the hubble
space telescope i did yeah that's not
and
come on and
you were not only just one of the many
missions that fixed it you were on the
last mission to fix it that's right and
that's the one that was at highest risk
of failure
right we were since we were the last
ones there was no one else to clean up
our mess how to get it right
after you fix it did you walk off like i
fixed it good yeah no way
it was my eliza was more like i hope i
fixed it good
and now and now apparently what neil's
saying it does work yeah it works it
works
it works yes our people i i got full
reports you did a good job thank you
yeah so buzz aldrin came through town
and i just had to nab him for an
interview he and i go way back
so it was it was a friendly like old
times
and so he came to my office and i wanted
to know how did he become
the guy to go to the moon not every
astronaut goes to the moon
not every person becomes an astronaut so
let's check it out i was in the same
squadron with ed white
supersonic f-100s in germany ed white
who was on apollo 1. that's right boston
and he left
he got me in the squadron then he left
and
went through the test pilot school that
qualified him to
be testing airplanes so
a little later he called me up and said
in 62 now i'm at mit and he says
nasa's looking for another group
astronauts and uh
i'm qualified and uh
i i think i'll love life another group
after the mercury seven
that's right the first one's after this
thing um
and i said i can shoot gunnery better
than you can
and besides that i'm i'm studying uh for
my
doctor's degree here and i've decided to
uh join up things in space
talking no not talking you can't
dock until you rendezvous
you gotta launch you gotta make a couple
of maneuvers
then you can rendezvous it's like
a fighter pilot uh
shooting down the other guy two moving
bodies that have to intersect
yes that this is bringing one on a
what you would like to be a perfect
trajectory
because you've looked at it and it's
just the one you studied that
i did it i did it before
and after shooting down a couple of migs
in korea
so mike how many migs did you shoot down
before you became an astronaut ah
zero so we got a little slice of the
right stuff yeah that's a little bit
that's a different
yeah so he was in the korean war shot
down migs
yeah and born in 1930 so that would have
been the age
in that era to do that right and so here
we are
drawing from this population right to
represent us
in space and back then they were all uh
military test pilots
and when the shuttle era came in 1978
they had a group of of astronauts that
were still the
the military test pilots but you had the
first astronauts of color the first
women who were astronauts and you had a
lot of scientists and engineers
we still have military people we still
have test pilots but we also have
you know men and women like me who are
academics academic and uh
phd in engineering correct a phd in
engineering and we have medical doctors
and scientists and people from all
so buzz you know he was he landed on it
was the first mission to to land on the
moon yeah
second to walk on the moon yes uh he had
his phd by then
and it seems he got a gold ring for each
one of those accomplishments
he's got a lot more
he was also the first to train
underwater to simulate weightlessness
that was his idea actually he was a
scuba diver and before his
uh his spacewalking adventure his
mission in gemini
they had trouble spacewalking on on the
gemini missions and
uh gene cernan ended up being the last
person on the moon during his spacewalk
on the gemini missions he fogged over
his helmet and had trouble getting back
inside
and they didn't really have a way to
it's it's interesting to hear these guys
talk about how do you spacewalk then
they just were just winging it
and buzz was the first guy to put some
science and engineering behind it
and he said training in the water he
spacewalked for five and a half hours
yeah he had all kinds he had things like
restraints and hand
and handrails and how to use your
tethers and how to train for it he
thought
he was really he is he's an academic
yeah he really i don't know how this
works let me figure it out right he came
up with that idea buzz did
and as we said before he's recently
written a book collecting his most
profound moments in space
so i asked him about them check it out
what's your favorite story that you tell
in here that you want the public to know
first guy to pee in his pants on the
moon
i was gonna ask you about that because i
have kids come up to me how do the
astronauts poop and pee
so because i looked inside the command
module of
the apollo command module there's no
restroom that you get up and go to
you know uh alan shepard's flight was
gonna be a
pretty short one so he was supposed to
go out there
get in this mercury
first time first american suburb
and the launch countdown didn't quite go
the way it was expected there was delay
delay delay
and alan's lying at his back
pretty soon it's getting pretty damp
there
and that's when they figure we we gotta
do something we gotta have a little bit
better
hydraulic engineering into the spacesuit
and the rest of it so they call it
hydraulic engineering
the ucd very important
urine collection device okay
and the ucd somehow i thought those
words would be
bigger it's just it's your it's a pea
collection device that's all it is
dumped overboard and and it freezes
me instantly yeah and there are flakes
but doesn't appear the stakes outside
where wait the p is moving the same
speed as your ship
of course it would right so if you put
it outside now the p
is frozen p is traveling alongside with
you to the moon
scott carpenter saw a lot of those
uh fireflies
and he was so fascinated with him
that he wasn't quite lined up for retro
fire
he he got the cosine of it which is
you know enough but there was a little
bit of the sign
of the angle that he's off
that's why he landed uh in the wrong
house where he is right
but the fireflies are you telling me
that was his pee
yeah it was a urine dump okay
the mysterious fireflies wow
but there was a little hesitancy about
people
are getting their jewel
too close to what was gonna
go to a vacuum like they might get
sucked outside
[Applause]
so we have to ask mike yes have you ever
peed in your pants in space
yes we can call the ucd we called it the
mag
the mag the maximum absorbency garment
it was a diaper diaper yes we were a
diaper on uh
launch and entry and while spacewalking
and then when you're inside the
spacecraft you use the toilet
okay so where does the p go if you do it
in the spacecraft
in the spacecraft it's collected and
then dumped as as he described then you
would want to see that the urine dump
was cool
because it would you would dump it and
it would crystallize and the sun would
shine on it and
and it was really beautiful fun it was
it was something i believe i'm having a
conversation
a beautiful frozen piece hey everybody
it's a urine dump ice right this is
hey it's a urine dump and we know before
you hit the switch i wouldn't go to the
window and watch
that's that's it so you're telling me
your pee
was orbiting the earth apparently yes i
never thought of it that way but yes for
a little bit until it crystal you know
it kind of disappeared no then it would
re-enter the atmosphere
uh well yes yes okay yes
you peed on earth oh my gosh
now now that you know the secret's out
that's it
uh more of my interview with american
national
earth hero buzz aldrin when star talk
[Applause]
[Music]
continues
[Music]
[Applause]
we're here at the american museum of
natural history in new york city and
tonight's show
is all about the legacy of the apollo
program and we are featuring my
interview with the one the only
apollo 11 pilot buzz aldrin let's check
it out
[Applause]
you're sitting on top of the saturn five
okay
ready to go to the moon does your
mortality
matter to you at that point that you're
sitting on this 32-story
controlled explosion
probably over pretty quick that would be
for sure
or or because many of you guys were
fighter pilots and test pilots
the idea that you're putting your life
at risk for some piece of machinery
was not a new concern of yours
everything that nasa did had a
reliability to it and it
ended up 95
you guys are gonna come back safely
we're pretty happy with that really
but what was the chance before we lift
off
of being everything to go or right and
not have to
abort further and safely
landing nobody was going to come up with
that number
but the three of us did 60 percent
is what we settled on this is you and we
landed
strong six out of the seven michael
cohen yeah
so if i i don't need to get morbid on
you but
if you had died on the moon yeah were we
ready for that
here in america here on earth every
president
they have a speech writer a staff
and a staff writer to the president
would of course prepare
in the event some
disaster unfolded like challenger
accident uh and it's not surprising me
at all but one would do that
but it kind of uh
not shocks but it brings people into the
reality
so i have some of those words that were
prepared in
case buzz aldrin and neil armstrong
would be stranded on the moon still
alive but we would know they would
ultimately die
these words were written for president
nixon and he never had to read them
but they exist and they're in his
presidential archives
fate has ordained that the men who went
to the moon
to explore in peace will stay on the
moon
to rest in peace these brave men
neil armstrong and edwin aldrin know
that there is no hope for their recovery
but they also know
that there is hope for mankind in their
sacrifice
these two men are laying down their
lives in mankind's
most noble goal the search for truth
and understanding
that's creepy but beautiful
when those guys were coming back they
had another launch to go through to get
off the moon that's why they were
talking about them
saying on the moon that rocket did not
work on the moon they were stuck
yeah and i think if if they were not
successful i think we would have
continued and we talked about that even
with the
with the uh shuttle accidents i remember
after we had challenger i became an
astronaut after that and before the
second mission
we said oh if you have an accident you
know it's going to end the program and
and it it didn't you know we had another
accident
and we kept going and and it's american
spirit
and in your particular case you you were
on
a dangerous shuttle mission we didn't
have a backup mission to save you that's
right and
you did this knowing you were at risk of
death
and you did this for we the
astrophysicists to fix
our telescope so i have to
assume the answer to this next question
is yes but i need you on record to say
so
was it worth the risk yes absolutely
absolutely yes it was
we got it we got
well thank you because i i don't know
how many people
even among my in my astrophysics
community who would have had enough of
the right stuff
to even have fixed our own damn
telescope so thank you
because you're not a national welcome it
gave me something to do
it's a telescope i think is a great
example of how engineers and scientists
kind of work together i enjoyed fixing
it you guys look through it and it's a
very nice relationship so
now you're up in orbit low earth orbit
350 miles up but buzz
is one of 12 people who have been to the
moon and
and i had to ask him about that
unique perspective the perspective of
setting your foot
on something other than earth let's
check it out
we always hear about astronauts human
beings
who have gone into space and they've
come back in some other
mental perspective are you
in another state of mind it's called the
overview
the overview you can have an overview
effect just being in orbit
yeah and then for the nine missions that
left
earth orbit to go to the moon
you now see earth receding in the
distance
that's gotta affect you in some way
that's home getting smaller
you know we'd be in trouble if it got
bigger
okay that's gonna happen later on later
on you want that on
on the back side of it you got to put
things okay all right so you expect it
to get smaller
it's getting smaller all is fine yeah
okay i hadn't thought about it that way
okay
so i he's not known for being
sentimental
you know he's he's just very
matter-of-fact and in fact
there's a famous photo of him saluting
the flag on the moon
he's quoted in his book it's saying
when he saluted the flag on the moon
he's not given to emotionalism
but in that moment patriotism and love
of country
overwhelmed him wow
and this is at a time where we're at war
with the you know at cold war with the
russians and
there's american flag is there and so
so did you feel nationalistic like i
mean you know patriotic like that
yes certainly i did i was very proud to
have an american flag on my left
shoulder
and uh when i was space walking it is a
lot of national pride we live in a great
country
and i think all astronauts go as
representatives of lots of things you
know the neighborhoods they came from
the schools they went to
and certainly the countries they're from
so was ever a moment where you had to
sort of override what would have been a
natural motion
to take care of some other task yeah you
know you kind of have to
keep things in check and a lot you know
for me a lot of it was
the emotional part of it really didn't
come out until i got back
and i started thinking about what you
did and any emotions allowed to escape
so i got very emotional
really the the day after i got back i
was thinking about stuff okay
you kind of hold it in okay so you're
completely human this is encouraging
yeah oh it probably takes you a while to
process that
just yeah it is you know i remember
getting back and just you know and you
start thinking about what you did and it
it really
you're allowed then to release at that
point and uh was it that's the way it
affected me but yeah
you have to you try to keep it in check
i think the you know the
the joyful emotion that's a no that's a
good thing
but the other the other side of it not
panicking you know when things are going
wrong
that's really important because you're
just going to make it worse so
cool well up next after the commercial
break our man about town chuck nice
goes into the public and explores what
people know or do not know
about the moon landing when star talk
[Applause]
[Music]
returns
we're back on star talk we're talking
about buzz aldrin's historic trip
to the moon and before we get back to my
clips of him
let's go to our man in the street chuck
nice to see what the public
thinks about the moon voyages check it
out
that's right neal we're here on the
streets of new york city to find out
what people think about the legacy of
the moon landing
did we even really go let's find out
do you believe we landed on the moon or
do you think it was a hoax i believe we
landed on the moon why
ah there's pictures we landed i mean i
wasn't there but
uh right but you know that we landed i
think so do you believe in bigfoot
uh no thank god i don't think that was a
hoax
that definitely happened i don't see how
it couldn't have been what if the earth
is a hoax but the moon
is real now see that i like the way you
think
did you ever want to be an astronaut
when you were a kid sure didn't
everybody back in my age
i mean i was born in 1954 okay i grew up
in the 60s when all that stuff was
happening
right and at least at some point
every kid wanted to be an astronaut at
that time and what did you end up being
a banker so much better moon people
where are my moon people so buzz aldrin
estimated that there was a 60 chance
that he would get to the moon and back
safely would you take those odds hell no
uh god no no i want to say yes but when
you're asking me
and thinking about my own personality
and i was a banker
no man has set foot upon the moon where
should we go next
everybody wants to go to mars like like
vulcan
land vulcan the planet vulcan mars is a
good destination i have to say though
if we had developed the sensing
technology that we have now like in my
cell phone and
all of the advanced ways to see
and perceive and and learn
before we had developed all the rockets
back in the early 60s
he might never have gone to the moon
really
because back in the day if you wanted to
learn what was happening in outer space
you couldn't send a robot couldn't
couldn't human being send a human being
now we can send robots or paintings
we're tiny stuff tiny stuff so
right so actually technological
advancement may have precluded buzz
aldrin from ever reaching the moon
you're the man you are i'm right science
so uh so i'm happy to report that
this set of random new yorkers in
washington square park none of them were
in denial
of the moon landing and so many people
are yeah yeah so i'm happy about that
happy to report
my fellow new yorkers we got it educated
city
so the um the the
the the lunar module as atlanta had a
name eagle
the eagle has landed this detaches from
the command module
that's the one this is the thing with
the spider legs which will take them
down to the lunar surface
and bring them back and landing on the
moon has no air so you can't use
air resistance to buoy or landing
they need fuel to slow down so they
don't crash
and you need fuel to lift off and return
all of this has to happen and so so
these different command modules
each one had a different command module
and it wasn't obvious which one would be
the first
what what what criteria was being used
depending on the needs of the mission
and so i asked buzz aldrin about how
his lander became the one chosen
for apollo 11. let's check it out
the lunar modules are coming off the
production line
and they're not assigning crews yet
because we haven't quite got there
but the crew shake up
because different things uh a lander
wasn't ready
and the russians were gonna maybe fly
around the moon
with a guy instead of just uh
uh empty we figured they were gonna put
a cosmonaut in there
so we accelerated uh apollo eight
anyway the landers coming off the
production line
uh we're heavy at first
and the first one that was going to be
light enough
was going to be a lamb six
and it worked out to be apollo 12 in
mid-october
all right now the manager of lem5 that's
your limp
yeah lunar excursion he wanted his to
land
and he went to george lowe the apollo
program had and he said george if
if i get the weight down will you
guarantee that my
lander will uh be a landing
mission george lloyd had a pilot program
says well of course i would like to have
another
chance an earlier chance to land so he
went ahead
and land five became qualified
and we landed instead of pete conrad
being the first on the moon
i did not know this until he told me
that i did not know that apollo 12 was
scheduled to be the first moon landing
with pete conrad the first to step off
the limb because that would have been
the lamb
light enough to to be served by the
limit
limit of the fuel available to send it
back and complete the mission
so that someone worked on their lamb
and slipped them in a head that i mean
that's that's that's amazing
i didn't know that either it's gangster
what i gotta do to make my limb land
first yeah yeah that's so gangster
that's right and of course what's
hurrying this along is that we have a
space race
with the soviet union and i don't know
how much people remember about that
maybe maybe some old-timers do but
others maybe you learned about it in a
book
but we were in cold war with the soviet
union
there it was okay and in that cold war
we're building up
our weapons arsenal and one kind of
weapon
which is particularly potent is the
intercontinental
ballistic missile so this is a missile
you launch and it
leaves the atmosphere of the earth and
travels most of its distance
sub-orbital then comes out of the
atmosphere and lands
and you would load them with nuclear
warheads and it can go between any two
points on earth within 45 minutes
you could not evacuate a city in time
because suborbital gets you halfway
around the
earth in 45 minutes and so so here's
what happens
just in case you don't know october 4th
1957 russia launches sputnik and you
read
normal accounts of it oh it's the first
space satellite okay that's cool
it starts the space race why did we
freak out
because that was in a hollowed-out shell
of an intercontinental ballistic missile
if they could fly a satellite that went
beep beep over our head
that was a that was of the writing on
the wall that was
they can send anything over our head and
we
went ballistic and
so so a year and a day later
i'm born but that's beside the point uh
a year later that week
the week i was born nasa is founded and
that births
our sp our participation in the space
race
so so then we actually launched the race
to the moon
with jfk speech because russia beat us
in almost everything else and he thinks
maybe
we could beat them again to the moon so
we launched that so that that's the
that's the story in a nutshell and we
have the mercury program the gemini pro
mercury holds one astronaut gemini holds
two gemini twins of course
uh apollo holds three and there you have
it
uh but during that apollo era we were
spending more than four percent of the
federal budget on going into space now
it's one half of one percent
of the federal budget so the valuation
is way lower but we did manage to do
other things we had sky lab
we had the apollo soyuz uh the sawyers
is the russian capsule
they connected remember that and of
course the space station did you ever
get to the space station i've never been
to the space station oh you have to go
you
must go why what's it like in the spring
how's the food
it's amazing everything's fresh good
service
so coming up after the break more of my
interview with moonwalker national
treasure
buzz aldrin when star talk continues
back on stockholm here at the rose
center for earth and space
and we're talking about the historic
mission to put a man on the moon
and back then in the age of apollo great
risks
were taken for great rewards and i
wondered
today is that same risk
reward ratio still in effect
and i ask apollo 11 pilot buzz aldrin
all about it let's check it out we're in
a culture now where everyone is afraid
to make a mistake because something goes
wrong and then
somebody has to hand out blame and i
worry
that we live in a time very different
from when i grew up
when we're sending you to the moon where
we're not
gonna discover anything because people
are gun shy
yeah exploration shy uh risk there
there's an engineer
who's made uh kind of a specialty
of uh of really analyzing how much it
costs
us to be so sure that something won't
fail we spend so much money to do that
we spend money to not fail not a lot
oh yeah not realizing the value of
failure in the first place
so maybe nasa needs a skunk works they
need a
a we got one we got one down in florida
what you already got alligators
but but this is kennedy space center
and they have a so if you're
if your launch fails no they get eaten
by alligator
swamp works okay down where the
alligators are
swamps and they are uh
getting into some so this is real
absolutely you know i didn't know about
the swamp works
what one of the one of buzz's favorite
quotes is a variant on the one we all
learned from
the apollo 13 movie uh failure is not an
option failure is not an option
and buzz has a different take on that in
his book he says nope
failure is always an option but one of
the lessons he describes
in that book because if failure is not
an option
then you're at risk of being too safe
and
in fact lockheed martin and the pentagon
and others have gotten together so they
had what was called the skunk works
where they would design advanced
uh aviation elements and out of that
came things like stealth
and very high speed craft
you know high mach number uh multiple
times the speed of sound
and and in that group they had very
little oversight
very little management telling them what
bottom line to
to match and only then did i just learn
that nasa has that i'm ashamed i didn't
know this
the the swamp works did you know about
the swamp works you know i had a student
a couple years ago that had a summer
internship there so i i
learned about it through him uh-huh do
you remember what stuff they were doing
they were doing some really cool robotic
stuff some like cutting edge cool
robotic stuff that this student without
some manager coming over saying you got
to make the bottom line
i think that's what that was the idea do
some exciting stuff it's a think tank
yeah think tank but they they're doing
more than just thinking yes
the build tank they're doing yeah thank
you it's a bill explosion it's a do tank
yeah it's a due tank and getting back to
the buzz and the risk
here's something interesting if you
don't know what you're risking your life
for
why risk it at all it's a good point
yeah if you just
not you don't have a defined goal just
go in space i don't know where
i don't know and then you put your life
at risk what's that about yeah it's not
it's not
really a great idea actually you know
and part of the reason as astronauts
were willing to take that where she
talked about hubble's because we knew
that something great could come out of
it so so you
were able to calculate the return on
that risk yeah because you know and plus
you knew we were watching if you came
back here and you would fail i would
have kicked well that's the other thing
you wouldn't be so you wouldn't have me
on your show if you screwed up your
telescope
exactly yeah so we added the mirror
failure wasn't an option in that case
neil would have been pissed so yeah
these astronomers would have been really
angry so we couldn't fail on that one
well so no just talk about not risking
no humans have been out of low earth
orbit
much less have been to the moon since
1972
yeah there's no new footprints anywhere
outside of low earth orbit we got i
think we got a footprint what do we have
on the screen here
there it is so it turns out that
footprint
is you know one small stuff for me
that's buzz aldrin's footprint that's
not neil armstrong
that's buzz now i don't know how they
all know that because i bet their boots
were pretty similar no way buzz would be
like mine were bigger
[Laughter]
any guy would so up next on star talk
we'll take your questions about the
apollo moon landing in the segment we
call
cosmic queries when we return
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to star we talk
this whole program to the apollo legacy
in my interview with
apollo great buzz aldrin and right now
it's time
for cosmic queries and this in this
segment we have solicited questions from
our fan base
all throughout social media i've never
seen them before if i don't know the
answer i'll just say i don't know the
answer
give me another one but i got you to
help me mike okay so give it to us let's
see what you got
from matt eli in san antonio texas why
do so many people refuse to believe
in the moon landing mike i
i think because it's such an amazing
feat we can't imagine that we actually
did it
and that's the only thing i could think
but i did it i actually agree i think
what a testament to how far our science
and engineering has come
that people within our own culture are
in denial
of what those achievements actually are
that is
an even greater testament to what the
achievements
have been so i'm totally with you on
that those are both incorrect
[Laughter]
forgot she's a game show host
next question is for casio keyboard are
you ready
from sir matthew 42 can you
once and for all explain to the moon
landing conspiracy theorists
why the radiation belt didn't kill the
apollo astronauts
ooh so did you go through the radiation
belt we were
waiting have you had kids since you no
i wonder why um well
the radiation belt and niels probably
can explain it's better than i can but
the radiation belt also protects us from
radiation it's when you get outside of
the van allen belts
where you're more exposed so they were
exposed once they got away from the
earth's
protection of our magnetic field but
they luckily did not get zapped with
anything
too harmful well yeah so so if i add
some some
nuance to that so so we have a magnetic
field
and charged particles come from the sun
which would otherwise be dangerous to
you
and they get directed to the poles
collide with our atmosphere
render it aglow into the aurora borealis
in the aurora australis the northern
lights
so credit the sun for that activity now
if you go into orbit go to the moon and
come back
if you're on the moon and there's a
solar flare a mega solar flare
that's bad for you right so future
emissions to the moon you want to time
it
for when the sun is not flare active and
the sun goes through cycles
so you know when it's at a low period
you're safer
the astronauts that went up back then
they were exposed to radiation but it
was not very much
and not all levels of all radiation are
bad for you not all radiation is bad for
you yes
that is the correct item okay what else
yeah what do we win
yeah what are we getting now keyboard
the keyboard casio keyboard okay
from nicole brooks in philadelphia how
would a soviet man moon landing have
affected the course of the cold war
oh hypothetically they would they would
they would have won
and uh it would have uh
uh i i i think would give them an edge
and maybe the soviet union might even
still be around today yeah
we might be calling it philadelphia now
like with an accident what i think
i think had they done that we would have
said uh no the real race is who lands on
mars first
yeah oh yeah we would have dang it yeah
yeah see
that's what i think we would have done
all right next one go last one
from beautiful dust specs
if the funding and backing for space
travel today was equal
relative she meant to say equally
relative to the funding of the apollo
program
what could be accomplished and what
would you prioritize as the top
objective
i'm gonna throw it to you neil okay so
now i wouldn't prioritize anything i say
make the whole solar system in our
backyard and if we had that same funding
nasa's budget would be ten times what it
is today
10 times and at 10 times the whole solar
system
is your backyard we'd have condos on
asteroids
well no no you wouldn't want to do that
but yeah
no i'm just saying are you vacationing
to the moon
the mars or you don't live in space so
bad oh but that's how
so that's so how it would be if nasa's
budget were 10 times what it is and i
wouldn't prioritize it
let people prioritize where they want to
go with whatever rockets they choose
it's not just one destination after
another let it all
let space be the destination nice
nice uh i would say we would we would uh
send people to mars and i think also we
would give us
uh more opportunity to fund some of
these commercial companies
and give them a little more seed money
because once we get them creative
and ways to make money i think it's
going to be uh
some some great accomplishments the
sky's the limit the sky's the limit once
that happens
you got it all right when star talk
continues
we're gonna feature our our regular
segment with bill nye the science guy
and we get his take on the legacy of the
moon landings
when stark talk continues
[Music]
we're back on star talk featuring my
interview with apollo 11 astronaut
buzz aldrin this guy walked
on the moon and he's not done yet
he wants us to go to mars and i have to
ask him about it check it out
you know what i-s-r-u yes
loving it yeah in-situ resource
utilization right
now i had to talk to that which is fancy
word for it
when you go there you can't bring all
your supplies figure out how to live
when you get there
now extract water first i want to say
what is the best
what is the most important thing that we
need for the future
rocket fuel to refuel
rockets heading for mars if you can't do
that
all of that has to be lifted up
oh is it so much more expensive
in time and everything else you are
filling stations throughout the solar
system
well we want one certainly
with a fair amount of fuel i love it
because
you've been trying to lead the charge
even the shirts you're wearing okay
get your ass to mars that is a brilliant
shirt brilliant i want to bring the rest
of my body as well as my ass
he wants to go to mars so badly that any
time nasa talks about going to the moon
he he he fights against it
yeah even if that's like the next thing
nasa wants to do he don't care
he wants to go to mars all right well
before we close out this show
as always i got to catch up with my
buddy bill nye the science guy
and i'm told he gave his thoughts on the
apollo
program while at the u.n
and i said what i haven't seen i haven't
seen it i just heard this is a dispatch
night times in the city from the u.n i
got to check it out
ladies and gentlemen in 1967
as the race to the moon was really
picking up speed
countries from all over the world came
together
and signed the outer space treaty
in it humans from all over the world
agreed
that no country no one could lay claim
to a celestial body like the moon and
and claim it for his her or itself
furthermore
the treaty holds that no one or country
can interfere with any life we might
find out there
this is the prime directive
i'm sure you or your friends are
familiar with it it's from star trek
can interfere brilliant
now it turns out that the prime
directive
is extracted entirely from the charter
of the united nations they both say
let's agree to prevent aggression either
military or
biological but the prime directive
is the same idea writ on a cosmic scale
back to you neil cool bill nye the
science guy
how did he get to give a speech at the
u.n how did that how do you i think you
sneak in when no one else is arrested
there's a back door i think that's what
yeah that kind of flipped the security
guard something
yeah they didn't show the what they
didn't show the the no one there yeah we
went on a sunday
so so what are your parting reflections
eliza i think without dreamers
we would never get to outer space so i
think the more we can encourage people
to dream no matter how silly or stupid
or
insane it sounds nobody's called crazy
when they actually succeed at something
anyone who succeeds is never called
crazy i like that
so so mike yeah yeah give me something i
think
oh man who has been in space yeah i
think i think it's great that you had
buzz on because he's really a national
treasure 12 only 12 people got to walk
on the moon
uh seven of them are still around and
it's great to to have him featured like
that
um what they accomplished was great but
it was a blip
right it happened it was a long time ago
we went there and came back
and the next time we go i think we
should settle in a little more
settle in you mean uh create a moon
colony yeah create a
colony uh settlement uh place to hang
out
research laboratory whatever you want to
call it i think we should go and stay
forever
so when i think about all this and
reflect
i think to myself there's an outer space
treaty
for the peaceful use of outer space so
the goal is when we all go into space
we will treat one another kindly and i
don't have the confidence that others
have in that
i want to believe it but i say to myself
if you
can treat each other kindly in space
then why not do that here on earth why
do you have to be in space
to not kill one another however
my one glimmer of hope is that so much
of human conflict in the history of
civilization has been derived
from scarcity of resources and access to
those resources
and i look at space asteroids comets
stars with limitless energy and i
realize
we should all realize that space is a
limitless supply of natural resources
space may be the only place
where peace is guaranteed because in
fact
we would have run out of all reasons for
why to kill one another
you've been watching star talk here at
the american museum of natural history
and i've been your host your personal
astrophysicist neil degrasse tyson
and as always i now bid all of you not
only farewell
but i require in life that you keep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
looking
[Music]
you